in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
today I'm with dr. risk analyses the
director of the charity Comprehensive
Cancer Center here at Berlin thanks for
inviting me into your clinic good
morning Frank morning immunotherapy
seems to be the next big thing in cancer
medicine could you please shortly
explain what it is immunotherapy has
been a big thing several times but
ultimately always failed but the basis
is understood quite well that is that
tumor cells carry mutations and tumor
tissue is not a healthy tissue so
there's apoptosis necrosis of tumor
cells and the earth is a dying it's yes
some tumor cells always die most stay
healthy but some die and they are taken
up by dendritic cells the professional
antigen presenting cells of the immune
system and those dissect the mutations
of the tumor cells and present them to
the immune effector cells and they get
activated and in turn return can kill
other tumor cells that is the ideal
situation and that may cause some immune
surveillance if new tumor cells develop
but in every patient with the cancer
this system has ultimately failed okay
so so and what does immunotherapy so for
a long time we used to stimulate the
immune system either by helping the
afferent way inducing immunity by cancer
vaccines and or by stimulating the
efferent system by interleukins by
herbal extracts like mistletoe extracts
and and stuff like that and this never
really worked it always worked in some
patients but not in many and now we
understood why the problem is there
because the immune system has very
efficient brakes and those barracks are
important to prevent autoimmunity so
it's a normal patient with no tumor
those those brakes slowing down
the immune system is very important
because otherwise the body would fight
itself yes it would cause immune
reactions against the gut against the
lung against endocrine glands and skin
and so a lot of autoimmunity would
develop but in cancer it's a totally
different story because you don't need
those it's basically the same story just
the tumor cells abuse the system and use
the same molecule that prevent the
destruction of normal tissue preventing
the destruction of themselves and put
those brace on the immune system and and
that is important too there's impossible
to overstimulate so in immunotherapy
fights those bright now the new
development has been to develop
antibodies directly against those breaks
that we can specifically and temporarily
take out the effect of the breaks either
in the afferent way that allows the
development of immunity if there is no
basic immunotherapy immunity that has
the risk of autoimmunity of course but
that is a temporary and also we can cope
with it and the other antibodies which
are very affected surprisingly effective
antibodies that target the breaks that
prevent the execution of immunity and
that has been powerful in a number of
cancers and also you can use both
together which is a bit dangerous
because automated when did you will
develop you have to cope with it but
it's very effective so the most feared
side effects would be an autoimmune
disease or autoimmune reaction so what's
it like for the patient it can cause
inflammation of the bowels of the lungs
of the skin and endocrine glands but we
have learnt to detect that early on and
treat it without compromising the
antitumor effects yet how big are those
entity effects partially it's dramatic
so in metastatic melanoma for example
where we have seen affectivity of
chemotherapy in less than twenty percent
of patients we can now have a
long-lasting effect and up to seventy
percent of patients which is a major
step forward and that is always long
lasting but also in many other tumors we
do
see long lasting or emissions and we
have to sort out know which molecule to
use best in which situation but the
effect overall is quite dramatic the
candidates when we think about
chemotherapy patients often complained
about side effects like nausea or weight
loss and how do those kills your product
drugs useless I effect where
chemotherapeutic drugs are poisons and
they kill fast-growing cells too much as
our fast-growing cells that is most of
them and therefore they're effective but
also normal cells are growing to some
extent the sense of the hairs we sense
all the blood system they are we going
every time and so there are inherent
side effects on these cell types that we
cannot avoid but then also the
gastrointestinal tract reacts and the
only way the gas return truck tracks is
by nausea so we just spoke about you
know therapy and q's era p and other any
other new therapeutic options on the
horizon well the other modality that is
developing is the molecule early
targeted therapies where we have
identifiable molecule yer operations in
the tumor cells that drive the
proliferation of thomas's if we find
those we can inhibit many of those by
specific drugs well if mutation causes
the proliferation of thomas's is the
driving mutations it has a certain
pattern and we can address that by
specific drug that blocks this driving
effect it does not work on tumor cells
that are caused by dysfunction mutations
where protein is dysfunction because the
dysfunctional protein you cannot detect
by where drug because it's not working
but if in those tumors where we have
driver mutation where we have the chance
to develop specific drugs or test
specific odds and some are licensed
which we can use to treat those patients
I recently with a story about anarchy
the media that they developed a method
they could reprogram cancer cells into
normal working body cells so what you
can do that is easy and that we have
already used in the eighties but
basically you can do that in the test Oh
and you can hit about seventy to eighty
percent of tumor cells and silence those
in a pain that doesn't help because if
only one percent of the tumor cells
survives it will regrow within a few
weeks and then there's no effect if you
try to look into the future what kind of
therapist who enters what's the best
strategy to fight cancer there's not
this magic therapy what is important is
to use all modalities we have we used to
have three modalities that was surgery
radiotherapy and chemotherapy and now we
have five of them the new ones are the
molecularly targeted therapy and also
the modern immunotherapy so on a
practical point of view if a patient
comes to you into the clinic with some
kind of tumor how do you decide which
kind of therapy
for most of the tumors we have standard
therapies and we know the effect and if
the effect is not satisfactory we start
sequencing of the tumor to see whether
we find driving mutations then it can
become complicated because some of those
driver mutation weekend addressed by
rocks we have in our armamentarium some
we cannot address at this time when you
don't do more research and also the
other way is of course to use the modern
immunotherapies and this is the decision
we have to take for every single patient
dr. Hannah thank you so much for letting
me interview came today